es ist nicht so häufig dass der
auswärtige ausschuss des bundesrates
takt und noch seltener ist die bundes
außenministerin zu gast vielen dank dass
sie heute da waren die kollegen und
kolleginnen ministerpräsidenten sind in
großer sorge aber auch in einer großen
entschlossenheit und wir wollen mit
dieser veranstaltung auch einmal
dokumentieren die deutschen länder haben
ein klares verständnis von dem was hier
gerade passiert ist ein großes
verbrechen was in der ukraine begangen
wird wir erwarten dass russland seine
soldaten zurückzieht den krieg beendet
wir sind der bundesregierung und ihnen
frau bundesministerin sehr dankbar für
die klarheit mit der sie in dieser
schwierigen phase deutschland vertreten
es ist hier eine große einigkeit
zwischen der bundesregierung und den
ländern
vor uns liegt eine große humanitäre
aufgabe wir sehen die frauen und männer
in unserer unmittelbaren nachbarschaft
in der ukraine einem europäischen land
viele von denen sind auf der flucht ist
zu einer million menschen in der zeit
schon dramatische
situationen und wir wissen viele von
ihnen werden nach deutschland kommen wir
als länder sagen deutlich sie sind hier
willkommen
kommen sie nach deutschland das ist eine
herkules aufgabe die vor uns steht jetzt
auch diese vielen großen menschenmengen
unterzubringen wir sind dankbar für die
große solidarität in der bevölkerung in
den kommunen und haben gerade auch
nochmal uns ausgetauscht wie das ganze
so zu organisieren ist dass wir unserem
anspruch als deutschland auch gerecht
werden es ist eine schwere zeit eine
zeit in der in der bundesrepublik
deutschland aber eine große
gemeinsamkeit herrscht und das glaube
ich kann auch den menschen in unserem
land mut machen soll ihnen mut machen
hier wird verantwortung gemeinsam
getragen herzlichen dank noch einmal
ihnen sie haben so viel positive
rückmeldung gerade in dieser runde der
ministerpräsidenten gehört ich will das
auch einmal noch bestärken ist absolut
richtig wir sind froh dass sie in dieser
schweren zeit verantwortung für unser
land tragen
herzlichen dank herzlichen dank auch für
die einladung in diesen ausschuss das
hat es so in der vergangenheit noch
nicht gegeben und so deutschland
unterstreicht in was für einer situation
wir sind die welt ist eine andere
nicht nur in der ukraine sondern eben
auch in europa und dass wir
zusammenstehen als europäerinnen und
europäer dass wir natürlich gemeinsam
mit unseren freunden und nachbarn in
polen in der slowakei in ungarn jetzt
menschen schutz geben das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber es
unterstreicht eben auch dass es hier um
die werte unseres gemeinsamen europas
unseres menschlichen miteinanders geht
und so wie die menschen in polen als ich
gerade dort war selbst gesehen habe mit
almas sie können vor ort unterstützen
regionale akteure unterstützen direkt
geflüchtete aufnehmen zu sich nach hause
einladen passiert das jetzt in diesen
stunden auch hier in deutschland und das
setzt eine enge zusammenarbeit zwischen
bund ländern und kommunen voraus und
deswegen auch mein herzlicher dank dass
wir uns genau darüber gerade austauschen
konnten wie wir gemeinsam auf allen
ebenen den menschen die alles verloren
haben wo oftmals jetzt mütter mit ihren
kindern kommen wo die väter in der
ukraine irland verteidigen wie wir diese
menschen unterstützen können und alle
bundesländer haben hier nochmal deutlich
gemacht dass sie natürlich gemeinsam mit
allen akteuren an einem strang ziehen
dass wir geschlossen die menschen die
jetzt in den zügen an den
unterschiedlichen orten unseres landes
ankommen dann unterschiedliche weitere
orte bringen gerade hier in berlin wo
wir heute sind ist ein bisschen der
anlaufpunkt von wo aus dann geflüchtete
weiterverteilt werden ich danke den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten dass sie dafür den
letzten tagen alles vorbereitet haben
weil es geht eben nicht nur um
unterkünfte es geht auch um
psychologische betreuung in so einer
situation
es geht darum ganz am anfang fuß zu
fassen und wir haben auf europäischer
ebene bereits dafür eine rechtliche
grundlage geschaffen die jetzt
pragmatisch ermöglicht dass menschen die
hier ankommen ein zuhause finden können
arbeiten können hier erstmal in
sicherheit sein können und das weiter
voranzutreiben daran arbeiten wir
zwischen bund ländern und den kommunen
jetzt ganz ganz eng im schulterschluss
gerade auch mit dem innenministerium die
die weitere federführung hier haben und
an dieser stelle glaube ich von uns
beiden und von der bundesregierung und
den bundesländern gemeinsam herzlichen
dank an sie alle in unserem land dass
sie deutlich machen wir stehen für die
menschen ein ich habe von vielen gehört
die sagen wir können auch zuhause
menschen aufnehmen das ist eine
besondere situation in der wir für die
vielen vielen menschen aus der ukraine
die von heute auf morgen alles verloren
haben ihr leben verloren haben jetzt das
tun können was wir tun nämlich schutz
geben in sicherheit geben damit sie in
den nächsten tagen in sicherheit leben
können daher vielen dank für diese
großartige solidarität bei uns hier in
ganz europa man muss sagen seit gestern
auf der ganzen welt vielen dank für die
einladung